all right let's talk about bill maher
bill maher says tokyo olympics are out
uh woking the oscars
proving cancer cultures and insanity
that is swallowing up the world have you
guys seen that video what do you say
right when you get a chance to see it
wonderful absolutely sick wonderful
absolutely sick by the way
bill maher today has replaced what jon
stewart was doing 10 years ago
okay do you guys remember when jon stood
brought nancy pelosi and called her out
on everything and she's like you can't
say that
you just cannot say what you just said
right there so it didn't matter if it
was left right middle we need people
like bill maher
so bill maher again another one of these
videos that went viral
please don't make the olympics into the
oscars bill maher says
last april as he reminded the audience
he said the theme of the year's
oscar show was we dare you to be
entertained as producers he griped
seemed determined not to let the
audience forget uh forget
for a moment the injustices and
deficiencies the human condition the
tokyo summer games
in mars view have outdone hollywood he
reeled off a series of instances where
officials and creative staffers
faced consequences over decade-old
behavior and in one case
the opening ceremony musical director
was ousted over a 1994 interview in
which he admitted a bullion fellow
students
when he was a child in school he also
radical media coverage of surfing uh
becoming an olympic sport in tokyo the
social press wrote
that having surfing in the games exa
exurbates
cultural appropriation with racial
indignities
that's because non-hawaiians have
popularized
and mainstream the sport with deep
spiritual and communal
meaning for its original participant the
article's headline described
the competition as whitewash event as to
changes
as to charges that he stands uh means he
has moved farther to the political right
a place on the spectrum giving to
reflexively denouncing cancer culture
mars said
my politics have not changed but i am
reacting to politics
that have powerful story by the deadline
it was a great video to watch patrick it
was i thought
i mean he was so spot on on so many
things and to talk about you know going
back when someone was six years old and
something they did as a kid and that's a
reason to terminate them today
that's just absolutely absurd but they
get away with it when is this canceled
culture gonna stop what is this whole
thing
when are people gonna stand up and say
enough of this
and just stop why do you think it's
creating so much momentum though
why momentum though that's the part you
know you know what cancer culture to me
is here's what cancer culture to me is
the only person that can do cancer
culture
is a person who can walk on water that
is the only person that has a moral
authority it's a witch hunt man
i don't know if you got what i just said
when i'm saying yeah yeah yeah yeah we
got you so if you walk on water
you listen you have all the right i'm
sorry i may hear you you know you're
right
i can't walk on water buddy if you can
walk on water try to cancel us
well what i want more than anything else
is uh for them to admit that they're
watching our podcast because that entire
dialogue is what we talked about on
thursday
you asked us why are we not watching the
olympics i said it's just not fun
anymore
the woke olympics aren't fun at all and
then we turned around
and we talked about the the look you
know
everybody thinks we're right-wing we're
this or that we're dead in the middle
man
the culture's gone so far left so fast
so when bill maher is saying that
i haven't gone right he's coming to the
same realization
that the rest of us have came and be
like man am i am i have i gone right if
i'm
am i thinking about no i'm here i've
been here
the culture's sprinting left so if
they're to the left of frickin trotsky
now
everybody's gonna seem to the right of
them even michael rappaport one of the
most annoying people on earth
this dude goes from on tuesday talking
about get your vaccine
or you're a jerk and then he's crying on
tick tock two days later like so let me
get this straight i can still
i can still get rid of the vet i can
still give people the virus if i get rid
of the vaccine i'm a super spreading out
like come on man
these guys they're having existential
crisis here because they're trying to
fit in
with this with this cult they want to
fit in with these elites but the elites
because that because they're worried
about the ramifications if they don't
and that's the thing is that they'll be
canceled out if they don't so
everybody's
everybody's treading so lightly this is
supposed to be the idealism
of inclusivity right all we want to
include we don't want you
except if you disagree with them because
as soon as you disagree with them that
you know so so long as you agree with
them then they want to include you
that's a good point guys send a guy send
a tweet uh
and he said to me you know cancel
culture by the way you guys know the
porn star we talked about she messaged
me very upset
she was happy with you though she liked
you a lot but she was upset with the
rest of us
and say what's up say what's up no she
said good things about you i gotta i got
a friend adam that'll buy you some white
clothes no no
not a fan of anybody else but he was a
fan of this so this one guy responds to
me and says have you noticed your view
numbers
on this are being censored meaning my
whole idea about trump and obama this
guy's saying have you noticed the views
on this have been censored
you're not getting views listen the only
thing that i see is the suggestion side
which you see the
if the audience wants to get this
message out there they can get the
message out here's what i said to the
guy
i said i don't believe the right message
can be censored long term
common sense can't be censored truth
can't be
censored temporarily yes permanently
no way in the world mario said that no
way in the world but mario said that
and he said that to us in a group checks
and it was it was a good point that he
says the truth always comes out
my fear my anxiety and my trepidation i
agree the truth always does come out
but it doesn't always come out in your
generation it doesn't always come out in
your lifetime
i don't want to live knowing that i was
lied to
and die knowing that the wrong people
maintained control
you know what's a flat carrier you know
what a fly carrier is what's a flat
carrier to you the definition of a flag
carrier don't know
what's a flag carrier when you think
about somebody that takes your message
and runs with it into the child and
so delivers it so flag carriers this is
going to sound a little weird and it's
not going to turn anybody on so brace
for impact this is not going to be that
exciting but it's going to
hopefully make some sense to what you're
saying here right and what you're asking
about here right now
some of us in life are flag carriers
some of us in life
are the byproduct of a flag carrier i am
a byproduct of my
dad and my mom sacrificing everything
they had including their marriage
everything they knew the language they
spoke the places they ate
they became the flag carriers to bring
their kids to u.s and my dreams became a
reality one of the best lines that grow
that lady said on fox and friend
she said here's a man who was born born
in iran but he's made in america
yeah kai's like that's got to be a book
one day born in iran made in america
right
okay my dad but my dad no one's going to
know my dad except for me telling the
world about my dad
my dad was a cashier at a 99 cent store
he's a flag carrier because of him
i work my ass off to make sure he for
the rest of his life can say
that's my son and the reason why he's
got the life is because i carry the flag
to allow him to have the life that he
has right is the man too sometimes he
loves you about he loves both of you
guys sometimes
we forget that we don't know what role
we're playing in life
okay sometimes you're not the one that's
going to be the next president
sometimes you're not the one that's
going to be the next billionaire the
next innovator the next governor the
next senator
sometimes you may play the role of a
flag carrier sometimes you may be
playing the role of a flag here in an
era that other people don't have the
courage to stand up and say here's what
we're going to be doing
but you're helping the next generation
win nobody wants that job who the hell
wants that job
who wants to be to be the veteran that
goes to war and defense for freedom for
other people in the back
that are going to spit him in the face
when he lands in the airport comes back
and saying who the hell are to go to war
like
did you do you realize how many of my
friends i just lost who the hell wants
to be that person
that's not going to be appreciated by
most people and then you lost two of
your friends and your life's on the line
what is a big deal about that that's a
flag carrier we have to go back to
recognizing these flag carriers that
have given us the opportunity to live
the life that we live today
george washington flag carrier lincoln
flag carrier mlk
flag carrier john fk jfk flag carrier
these are flat carriers they carry the
flag for us to have a better life
i think uh you know the idea of not
wanting to be a flag carrier is the fact
that some of us are not going to lose
you know are going to lose some of our
opportunities having our dreams become a
reality i want my kids to have the
opportunity to live the life they want
to live so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you